now the thing I love about weed too is
it's not too strong tonight I'm gonna go
out after these shows I'm gonna smoke a
bunch of weed and weed's gonna rock it
with me all night long till the wheels
fall off weed's Gonna Take Me Home
Tonight
yeah weed's gonna put me in bed
and then weed's gonna get in next to me
pull the covers up outside spoon me all
night tonight
I'm sleeping like a baby tonight
okay not alcohol alcohol wants to go out
all night too rock until the wheels fall
off but see alcohol don't want us to
sleep in the bed alcohol wants me to
sleep between my toilet and my [__]
sink with my arm bent around my head
well I throw my nuts up into the toilet
and then on top of it wants to [__] my
night pants
weed ain't my night pants